i mean the taliban used to shoot
televisions
they used to you know blow up
vcr um you know videotapes um
they used to string
audio and video cassettes from trees and
kind of ceremonial hangings right that
we're we're killing this nefarious
infidel technology that is doing the
work of satan and yet today
at last i mean one of the keys to the
top on success is that they got really
good at using media
i mean brilliant at using
a
dirt and word the spoken word music
actually
and
you know hollywood hollywood is the gold
standard and these guys have studied how
to create drama
how to speak to modern users i mean
islamic state did this i mean the role
of media new media i mean
i am i follow and i am followed by
senior top on leaders which is
you know bizarre you know on twitter
on twitter i don't know why they care
about me i'm i'm nothing uh they [ __ ]
their fault they follow you on twitter i
don't know why this is no joke this is
no joke so it's they're part of our
modern world and how they talk is how
they recruit and this is part of the
this is why they are you know so so bin
laden if you bin laden he
he speaks multiple languages i would say
it's uh
it's
environmentalism
you know the west is bad because we
destroyed the planet the west is bad
because we abuse women
so in class you know uh especially you
know female students
are very surprised to learn and actually
say you know this this feminist argument
is not
you know we start with you know this is
a murderer
this is a person who has taken human
life innocent life over and over again
and he is um
you know
aspirationally genocidal
but let's try to understand what he's
about so we walk through the text read
them and people are
shocked to learn that
it's not just about
you know quotations in the quran strung
together in some irrational fashion
he knows um
i mean at the core i'd say is the
problem of human suffering
and he has a geography of that that is
mostly muslim but he talks about the
suffering of kashmir all right so if you
have a student in your class
who's from south asia who knows about
kashmir
you know he or she will say
that's not entirely inaccurate you know
you